the audience comes last in service to  the audience  the audience wants the best thing they  don't get the best thing while you're  trying to service them they get the best  thing when you're servicing yourself  when you're when you're true to who you  are in my case I bet every decision I've  made from  working in a different genre than I  started in every time every time I do  something different or new  always told not to do it I'm always told  it's a terrible idea well the idea that  the audience would dictate to the artist  what to do because this is what we want  is insanity right Insanity it's the  artist's job to express themselves in a  way that makes the audience think  differently or feel something yes and  the audience doesn't necessarily know  that yet yes Steve Steve Jobs said you  know famously  the consumer doesn't know what they want  until you make it